/
hola buen día bienvenidos una vez más a
esta emisión semanal de canadá en las
américas café el programa que les ofrece
la sección en español del radio canadá
internacional en esta ocasión estamos
aquí en el estudio una versión reducida
del equipo paloma martínez
descansada vuelta del viaje si voy muy
bien con ganas de trabajar sigue
perfecto y mi nombre es luis laborda ya
estamos en una versión reducida del
equipo el resto del equipo está
descansando ocupándose de otras tareas
de otras cuestiones pero no estamos
solos sentados acompañados y tenemos el
estudio lleno de gente ahora le vamos a
presentar en un segundo más a nuestras
invitadas porque son todas las mujeres
si tienen que ver con la fecha con la
que recordamos con la fecha que
recordamos en el día de hoy pero antes
de eso queremos recordarles que como
siempre tienen ustedes diversas vías de
comunicación diversas vías de contacto
con esta emisión con canadá en las
américas café a través de facebook
a través de nuestro canal de youtube y
por supuesto como siempre en nuestro
sitio en internet www que eres y nets
punto ce a enseñar donde la misión está
desde primera hora de la tarde hasta la
mañana del lunes o si se queda todo el
fin de semana efectivamente y hoy 8 de
marzo se celebra se conmemora se
recuerda se festeja el día internacional
de la mujer que es una fecha que fue
instituida formalmente en el año 75 por
naciones unidas pero que se celebra
desde mucho antes de los primeros años
del siglo pasado desde 1911 más
precisamente y es una fecha que intenta
recordar en la lucha de la mujer por su
emancipación o en todo caso por la
igualdad de derechos respecto al hombre
escuché esta mañana el bis que la
llamaban ahora varias personas el día de
los derechos de la mujer
antes era el día de la mujer
primero fue el día de la mujer
trabajadora exactamente hemos pasó a ser
el día de la mujer el día internacional
de la mujer después pasó a ser el día de
la mujer y ahora creo que es el día de
los derechos de la mujer sí
efectivamente pero pero el motivo
siempre siempre me más que es reconocer
el rol que juega la mujer en la sociedad
y vamos a desarrollarla con nuestras
invitadas que tenemos hoy aquí nada
menos que cuatro invitadas así que la
mesa está llena antes de darle paso a
esas y decirles quiénes son les recuerdo
que a quienes nos siguen a través del
sitio internet podrán acceder a la
música que no solemos pasar por
cuestiones técnicas y de derechos
etcétera etcétera
aquí en directo pero más tarde en la
edición que encuentran en el osito
intranet tendrán acceso a esa música en
esta ocasión un artista que ya es
conocida del público porque le hemos
puesto aquí en más de una ocasión que es
office anne marie louise le encantaba
office and mary eso de las artistas
canadienses que no me gusta más
recientemente por nuestro set no por los
nuestros pero nuestros colegas
de civil y de radio canadá internacional
en inglés estuvieron conversando con
ella y todos pasaron por los pasos por
los pasillos porque no lo saludo
bueno tendremos dos temas musicales de
ella de este artista de raíces indígenas
que además también está ligada a la
temática de hoy porque es una mujer que
ha combatido por los derechos de la
mujer indígena además de otras causas
múltiples causas en las que ella está
involucrada y hoy vamos a ofrecerles dos
temas musicales interpretados por
bosques ámbar y que son cantemos nuestra
propia canción y el poder de la sangre
eso para quienes accedan al canal en las
américas café pura y exclusivamente en
nuestro espacio vip del sitio en
internet
bueno y ahora decíamos que tenemos
invitadas para hablar del tema del día
internacional de la mujer de la
problemática de la mujer
estas invitadas son por un lado teresa
zambrano que pertenece al organismo
found dumont de kotak órdenes mujeres
del mundo en el barrio de cortínez que
es uno de los barrios de la ciudad de
montreal buenos días y bienvenidos a
teresa buenos días gracias en gusto
tenerlo aquí muy bien muy amable luego
está también con nosotros
amelia moreno almería moreno es el
movimiento contra la violación y el
incesto de montreal bienvenida amelia
buenos días luis contenta de estar aquí
también muchas gracias por haber
aceptado nuestra invitación tenemos
también a mónica peña sí que es
integrante de la cooperativa de la
misión de summer y así es buenos días y
gracias por la invitación encantada
perfecto y esa cooperativa es la
cooperativa de la casa de las américas
podríamos decirlo así en español y por
último victoria bautista bueno que es un
militante por los derechos humanos
originaria de méxico así es buenos días
un placer estar con ustedes perfecto
muchísimas gracias victoria tú también
por estar aquí con nosotros
tengo una pregunta de entrada se conocen
entre ustedes
bueno pero podrían haber sido
simplemente muy corteses y no conozco a
tere ella también es socia fundadora de
la casa las américas otra de las mujeres
de las 16 mujeres de 29 socios
fundadores que somos entonces si nos
conocemos bien y yo tuve la oportunidad
de conocer a victoria en méxico en el
foro internacional mundial sobre
inmigrantes ellos presentaron también
toda la problemática de las mujeres
desaparecidas
bueno y para iniciar esta conversación
está esta charla esta mesa de homenaje a
la mujer en el día de hoy aquí en canal
en las américas café les propongo que
comencemos por dar cada una de ustedes
una reflexión qué significa qué sentido
tiene para ustedes el día internacional
de la mujer quien quiera comenzar quien
puede arriesgar una opinión al respecto
pero eso yo quiero decir que la lucha de
las mujeres no solamente para arrancar
uno u otro derecho al sistema
capitalista no la lucha por las mujeres
es para vivir en una sociedad liberada
de cadenas que oprimen a la mayoría de
las personas que son mujeres muy bien
bueno yo quería también decir que el día
de hoy nos ayuda a hacer reflexiones y
yo pienso que el panorama de la mujer no
es muy positivo la violencia y sobre
todo la violencia sexual con la que
nosotros trabajamos es sistema
sistemática en todos los países hay
desde operación estructural muerte y eso
lo vamos a ver cuando ya trabajemos con
el zinc con los servicios que nosotros
prestamos así que el panorama es triste
no solamente en otros países de américa
latina aquí también aquí también por
ejemplo
las mujeres indígenas son desaparecidas
y las mujeres canadiense no son
reconocidas en sus demandas así que
siento que el panorama no es el mejor ni
el más positivo en relación a la
violencia contra la mujer con lo cual el
día internacional de la mujer sirve
entonces en ese sentido para destacar
que no todo está resuelto no es cierto
reflexión sí exacto mónica para mí
significa un día en donde tenemos la
oportunidad de conocer quiénes ya
pasaron a este camino ya luchar por
nosotras quienes han abierto brecha y
quiénes estamos abriendo brecha
actualmente
personalmente yo soy emprendedora y
el empoderar a las mujeres a través de
actividades económicas me parece
indispensable y es un día que nos
permite conocer cómo estamos y las
realidades de todas las mujeres porque
todos tenemos diferentes realidades
entonces es un día para reflexionar
perfecto y victoria
hoy se un día en el cual bueno debería
de ser todo el año no pero hay un día en
especial que soy el 8 de marzo en el
cual debemos de seguir levantando la voz
para que no se sigan violando los
derechos de nosotras las mujeres porque
vivimos en un país o en un lugar donde
la mujer la reprimen y ahí realmente
juegan con nuestros derechos cuando
hablas de un país en donde la mujer es
reprimida habla del estado de medio del
país de méxico si clicks lamentablemente
uno de los países en américa latina que
tiene un nivel de violencia contra la
mujer más alto en todo el sur del
continente nació correcto y uno de los
temas particulares louis que yo quería
mencionar es que justamente hoy en la
mañana salió la ley informaciones fueron
publicadas de un sondeo en el que la
mitad de las mujeres canadienses que
fueron sondeadas dicen tener al menos
una amiga que ha sufrido acoso sexual
entonces no solamente es una realidad de
méxico donde sí y donde en muchos países
latinoamericanas pero incluso acá en
canadá sigue habiendo situaciones de
vulnerabilidad de la parte de las
mujeres que siguen siendo terribles
ayer se entrevistaba a una profesora de
la universidad de ottawa que conoce muy
bien a américa latina ha hecho diversos
estudios diversas investigaciones y
hablaba a ella en este caso en
particular específicamente del tema de
la mujer y resaltaba lo que decíamos
hace un instante con amelia que hay
cosas que falta todavía resolver pero
también señalaba que es precisamente
américa latina' la parte del planeta en
la que las mujeres han adquirido de
manera tal vez impensada hace un tiempo
un rol mucho más activo que en otras
partes del mundo y donde la represión
esos movimientos sociales
explica precisamente por qué esa
reivindicación que lleva adelante la
mujer es efectiva consigue resultados
que no son tan frecuentes ver o no son
tan círculos no son tan frecuentes
constatar en otras partes del mundo en
ese caso en el caso específico de este
tema media tú estás de acuerdo ahí a
pesar de todo un progreso importante de
américa latina en los derechos de la
mujer es muy importante yo siento que el
hecho de que haya habido tanta violencia
y si ya bien habiendo las mujeres se han
organizado y se organizan
permanentemente porque dijimos basta ya
este tipo de violencia va hasta las
desapariciones a la muerte de nuestras
hijas pero la violencia se ha
identificado también muy fuerte hacia
las mujeres que son líderes y las
desapariciones son permanentes ahora
decíamos que méxico era como uno de los
países que más desapariciones había pero
yo pienso que no se ha hecho denuncias
fundamentales colombia en este momento
está de mujeres están desapareciendo las
líderes y la impunidad es total en este
país y eso que estamos en un proceso de
supuestamente exacto imagínense que a
nivel internacional no se conoce esa
realidad de colombia y esa esa falta de
esa carencia de denuncias en todo caso
tiene que ver con el temor al ser a
seguir siendo reprimidas porque la
represión no ha desaparecido a pesar de
los procesos de paz formales la
represión no se ha extinguido y entonces
hay muchas mujeres y no solamente las
mujeres en algunos casos del resto de la
sociedad que están aún inmersos en el
miedo de denunciar los actos de
violencia bajo todas sus formas porque
las represiones todavía reales es
palpable y es factible y digamos que
se endureció esa represión sobre todo
después del proceso de paz cuando las
mujeres líderes campesinas empezaron a
tratar de organizar su pequeña comunidad
y entonces fueron reprimidas por ser
vistas como una amenaza todo lo que
suene a organización
está visto con una mirada entonces las
mujeres a pesar de eso en colombia
siguen organizándose y por ejemplo el
grupo ágape por colombia que trabaja por
la paz y la reconciliación que es un
grupo de mujeres que se inició aquí en
canadá que van a colombia y que dictan
talleres de paz y reconciliación están
trabajando por que esa paz sea posible
pero es muy difícil no se va a bajar los
brazos pero es muy difícil luchar contra
gente armada gente violenta que no
acepta un proceso de paz que la mayoría
está aceptando entonces es es un sí pero
todavía no pero las mujeres estamos ahí
como decía una compañera como punta de
lanza en la primera fila de la lucha ahí
seguimos y siguen desapareciendo
desapareciendo y asesinando líderes en
mujeres pero ellas van a seguir en la
lucha
mónica esta estaba usted mencionando
está usted hablando de la emancipación
de las mujeres a través de los de la
economía a través de la de la libertad
digamos económica que puede representar
digamos por ejemplo un salario mínimo
más elevado o una equidad en cuanto a
los salarios que reciben las mujeres y
los hombres esta mañana la federación de
mujeres de quebec estaba manifestando
por las calles hablando de que el
salario mínimo de 15 dólares
representaría para las mujeres un gran
cambio en cuanto a su en cuanto a su
libertad económica absolutamente y
recordamos también que las mujeres
tienen la mayor carga de actividades
diarias entonces esa libertad que da el
tener un ingreso adicional no es muy
importante y por eso también las
actividades de emprendedurismo son
vitales en las sociedades porque
empoderan y liberan a la mujer le da la
flexibilidad no de tener un trabajo fijo
porque si hay que por el niño o si hay
que tener actividades llevar la casa si
quieren innovar incluso en su trabajo
están muy muy acotadas en el ámbito de
acción
entonces las actividad de
emprendedurismo empoderan digamos tiene
un efecto multiplicador y actividades de
emprendedurismo como el de la casa de
las américas que es una cooperativa en
donde vas acompañada en donde conoces
otros modelos empresariales en donde hay
otras mujeres que lideran el proyecto
empoderan aún más porque cuántas mujeres
conocemos que dicen uy yo no sé por
dónde empezar si tengo ganas de empezar
un proyecto tengo ganas de abrir mi
negocio pero no conozco las herramientas
no conozco los caminos a tomar no
conozco los aliados estratégicos a
quienes me puedo acercar
y proyectos como la casa de las américas
empoderan a las mujeres al decir ven con
nosotros iniciamos un proyecto juntas
aprendemos juntas y nos acompañamos
además imagino que la realidad debe
modificarse debe cambiar debe ser
absolutamente diversa en un lugar y otro
del planeta si tomamos en cuenta a una
mujer que quiere iniciar un proceso de
emprender una actividad aquí en canadá
supongo yo presupongo que debe ser menos
complicado que hacerlo en américa latina
si es en los factores culturales
sociales y económicos no de cada país
incluso de cada ciudad no sabemos la
diferencia aquí montreal toronto no no
es lo mismo emprender una empresa
cultural en montreal que en toronto por
los los factores que con los que tienes
que jugar son muy diferentes ahora si
hablamos de mujeres de canadá en
montreal no hay mujeres que están en la
en la ciudad de mexico
las cargas y yo yo lo veo yo tengo dos
negocios en méxico
estoy soy socia fundadora de la casa de
las américas buscando extender también y
buscar mercados para mis negocios de
mexico
y la realidad cultural te limita y lo
vemos platicando y en la mañana que nos
conocimos
la situación en méxico en mi socia en mi
hermana y tuvo un este intento de
secuestro no hace algunos meses y
entonces asaltaron en nuestro negocio la
semana pasada entonces pues claro que
empieza a generar factores no de decir
cuál es mi viabilidad como empresaria no
se dieron cuenta que es un negocio
dirigido por mujeres y entonces nos
vuelve más vulnerables como negocio no
empiezas a cuestionarte y yo que trabajo
temas de género son factores que pones a
la mesa y es que está sucediendo y por
eso es que las las iniciativas de los
grupos de base de los gobiernos deben de
ir enfocadas a reconocer esas realidades
de las mujeres en cada localidad en cada
ciudad para darle el ecosistema
necesario para que puedan fructificar
ser fructífera sus negocios perfecto
victoria la violencia contra la mujer es
un fenómeno social es un fenómeno
cultural en todas partes del mundo pero
en el caso específico de méxico tiene
que ver
con una relación íntima con el poder
sabemos que se han comprobado en
diversas ocasiones los vínculos entre
fuerzas las fuerzas de seguridad o las
fuerzas armadas el ejército e incluso la
policía con grupos que tienen que ver o
que están ligados de alguna manera si es
que no son ellos mismos el narcotráfico
la trata de personas la distorsión esa
realidad en méxico aún persiste no ha
cambiado si en la realidad que comentas
que es exactamente lo que es lo que
estás comentando en la realidad que se
vive en méxico no esté colores pero a mí
me llevo el caso de mi padre que fue
este desaparecido una desaparición
forzada en 2011 7 de diciembre me llegó
a ser una luchadora social no de
defensora de los derechos humanos por ya
través de todo ese camino éste me llevó
a conocer a muchas mujeres que han sido
desaparecidas que les apasiona sus hijos
pero todo está relacionado entre el
gobierno crimen organizado no que casi
es lo mismo y en el caso específico de
tu padre a qué se debió
mi padre era este defensor de derechos
humanos
teníamos tenemos una organización de
campesinos este de la sierra de petatlán
él era presidente y el que llevaba la
organización entonces él era defensor
del bosque y aparte defensor de los
derechos humanos entonces él tenía mucha
relación con diversas organizaciones
afines al medio ambiente en méxico donde
se llevaban reuniones cada mes entonces
él tenía que viajar y también ya
hacíamos mucha gestión con el este con
javier sicilia este y él viajaba un día
viajó y lo levantaron
'este interceptaron el autobús donde él
viajaba en la noche como las seis de la
mañana cinco de la mañana entonces uno
dos tres camionetas según testigos éste
nos informaron que e interceptaron el
autobús donde él iba subieron militares
lo identificaron que iba a y
posteriormente siguió el autobús y otra
vez interceptaron y llega la
delincuencia y quien lo bajó no entonces
llevan directamente a sus
a su asiento
voy a cambiar un poco de tema pero
siempre es en la cuestión de otro tipo
de particularidad que tienen que tiene
que ver con la relación en la equidad
entre hombres y mujeres y ayer la onu
sacaba un informe en el que decía que la
equidad entre mujeres y hombres sería
posible si los hombres se implicarán más
en las tareas domésticas si los hombres
hicieran la misma cantidad de cosas que
las mujeres hacen en la casa simplemente
se eliminaría una parte del peso digamos
que cargan las mujeres con respecto a
las acciones en la en la en la casa qué
piensan ustedes desde esta postura de la
onu en la que dice probablemente que la
violencia probablemente que la que la
ine
igual en igual cantidad entre mujeres y
hombres podría tener un podría
terminarse si compartieran más los
hombres y las mujeres si a media
pues yo pienso que podría ayudar un poco
digamos que las mujeres se le descargar
un poquito el trabajo que solamente
tiene que no solamente hacerlo en el día
sino cuando llegue a la casa pero yo
creo que el problema es más de fondo y
no es de ayudar un poco a la mujer no
ayudarle es ser súper o hacer su parte
el problema es que vivimos en una
sociedad patriarcal en unas relaciones
de poder supremamente grandes y en esas
relaciones de poder la desigualdad hacia
la mujer es total y la violencia no se
va a mejorar si no hay unas relaciones
de poder diferentes con la ayuda o con
la parte solamente en tareas cotidianas
que se hicieran en el hogar yo pienso
que tiene razón las tareas en el hogar
deben ser iguales pero en la sociedad
también debe haber equidad en el trabajo
debe haber igualdad de salarios debe
haber igualdad de oportunidades en el
estudio en la salud porque si no de qué
sirve solamente que el hombre ayude o
haga su parte en el hogar se necesita
que haya cambios a nivel legislativo que
las leyes cambien si las leyes no
cambian
para poder hacer efectivo el derecho de
las mujeres y alcanzarlas porque con la
persona con la que ayer casualmente
hablábamos del sistema también y se me
decía me nombraba a algunos casos de
países en los que se han aprobado
recientemente leyes muy avanzadas pero
el problema después una vez que esas
dices están aprobados es que no se las
aplica no se las lleva a la práctica
porque la ley podrá estar muy bien
inspirada y haber sido incluso aprobada
con un caudal de votos importante en la
legislatura del país del que se trate
pero si no existe la voluntad de cambiar
del esquema de poder como decíamos
recién
no hay cambio real por más de iu que
promulgue ese cambio es que la ley no
puede quedar solamente en el papel la
ley tiene que hacerse efectiva y tiene
que ser algo que las personas en este
caso los hombres lo asuman mentalmente
que entiendan qué es lo que pasa si
ellos no aportan a este cambio porque
ellos también están perdiendo todos
estamos perdiendo en la sociedad si
continuamos con esta limitación de las
mujeres quería decir algo si mónica yo
concuerdo con amelie con tere es
definitivamente algo que se requiere es
algo que se necesita pero no me parece
que también no es lo único que generaría
un cambio en el comportamiento de la
sociedad un cambio cultural porque lo
que estamos es un cambio en la cultura
no hay como tenemos nosotros la
percepción de nuestras estructuras
sociales de nuestras relaciones sociales
de nuestras interacciones con los
hombres
es algo sumamente complejo que tampoco
se es desde el punto de vista tampoco se
ve se sustenta únicamente en lo legal
definitivamente es un es un elemento
indispensable en la fórmula así como el
que el que hagan sus actividades en la
casa no es un elemento indispensable
pero va más allá y es el cómo forjamos
una sociedad que esté dispuesta a
cambiar esas estructuras sociales esa
cultura esa forma de vernos a los ojos y
de definir nuestros comportamientos
vamos a hacer una pequeña pausa y ya
bueno sobre ese eje precisamente y cómo
se cambia la sociedad
[Música]
y la pregunta entonces está lanzada para
la mesa como cómo se cambia la actual
estructura social que permita que la
mujer goce de ahora en más de iguales
derechos a los que disfrutas desde hace
tanto tiempo el hombre si yo quiero
compartir un poco lo que hacemos en el
fondo mundo y es si nos reunimos tomamos
un café vemos una película pero también
compartimos cuáles sería cuáles son las
causas fundamentales de la situación que
vivimos tenemos que ir a allá al fondo
de esas causas fundamentales para
entender el problema que enfrentamos día
a día y ver cómo vamos a cambiar las
estructuras sociales cada una desde
nuestra actividad como mujer desde
nuestra profesión podemos hacer que eso
cambie individualmente en grupos en
comunidades y cada vez más grandes pero
tenemos que ir a las causas si no
cambiamos las causas entonces solamente
hacemos arreglos pequeños como poner
parches y tos aquí y allá donde duele
pero lo que necesitamos cambiar es la
estructura como tal
si nosotros también en el movimiento
contra el violín encestó y ayudamos a
las mujeres que tomen conciencia que el
problema la violencia no es individual
es un problema de sociedad es un
problema sistémico y las empoderamos o
sea les ayudamos a que ellas superen las
consecuencias de la agresión porque se
convierten en mujeres muy vulnerables y
que tomen y se apoderen de ellas mismas
pero también hacemos mucho trabajo de
sensibilización en las escuelas en los
colegios las instituciones para ser
conscientes de la realidad de la
violencia que se vive en las mujeres y
para mirar cómo podemos realmente
pelearnos el derecho a que si las leyes
existen sean cumplidas hacemos parte de
varios comités también para movilizarnos
y hacer que esas leyes sí se cumplan y
sensibilizar a la población en general
vamos a volver más tarde sobre el tema
específico de la violencia sexual que he
estado en las primeras páginas de todos
los medios desde hace ya tiempo en los
últimos en el último año y medio dos
años por lo menos pero quería seguir
donde la palabra arresto a la mesa para
que nos digan
aunque es lo que hay que cambiar creo
que es una cuestión de generar
conciencia en la sociedad hombres y
mujeres por igual de quitar ese miedo de
vernos al espejo y me parece que es un
gran reto el generar conciencia el que
las personas se construyan y sean
capaces de reconocerse
y reconocer a sus a sus colegas a su
familia etcétera es un reto es un reto
muy grande pero es a través de la
conciencia victoria si concuerdo es
concientizarnos tanto hombres como
mujeres que tenemos como los mismos
derechos y las mismas oportunidades para
poder desarrollarnos en una sociedad y
hablábamos recién de la violencia sexual
del abuso sexual contra las mujeres es
un tema que ha estado en la picota en
los últimos tiempos a partir de
denuncias que se han producido en
distintas partes del mundo seguramente
algunas de las más resonantes son las
que se produjeron en eeuu en donde el
tema del abuso sexual afectó a la
industria del cine una más importantes
en ese país pero que no es por supuesto
ese país es una realidad en todo el
mundo en países del asia en países de la
áfrica por supuesto también en américa
latina y aquí el organismo que tuvo
representa esa media de morera o que tú
íntegras en todo caso en el movimiento
contra la violación y el incesto de
montreal como aborda la problemática de
la violación de la mujer si realmente es
una problemática muy dolorosa en este
momento nosotros tienen una lista de
espera de seis meses más o menos 250
mujeres que están en espera que nosotros
les acompañemos en todo lo que es el
proceso de ayudarlas a sobrellevar ese
es la problemática de la violencia y la
vejó la cifró por favor 250 mujeres
están en espera
y 6 meses de espera no tenemos mucha
ayuda del gobierno nosotros recibimos
mujeres de acá de mujeres inmigrantes de
primera y segunda generación y mujeres
en demanda de asilo
somos los raros un poco un poco del
organismo casi raro que trabaja con las
mujeres demandas y lo porque este
servicio no se les presta
decidimos mujeres que vienen de colombia
que vienen de venezuela que vienen de
haití
que vienen del salvador y que vienen de
méxico y de otros países y que han sido
víctimas de la violencia sexual no
solamente a nivel digamos de la familia
sino a nivel político porque las mujeres
son utilizadas también como como la
violencia para poder como una arma arma
de contra contradictoria entre los
diferentes grupos y también las
violencias colectivas que se viven por
organismos como por ejemplo los zetas en
méxico los maras en el salvador las
situaciones supremamente dolorosas y la
violencia sexual digamos en méjico con
mujeres por ejemplo que son casadas con
militares y aunque no lo sean no pueden
ser denunciadas porque si denuncian el
peligro es aún mayor en colombia también
y hay una impunidad total
frente a las mujeres y ellas denuncia la
corrupción que hay también en los
estados de protección del estado no
toman en cuenta sus de noches entonces
estas mujeres se unirá realizan cada vez
más aquí también las mujeres son muy
polarizadas porque así aquí se ha
considerado la violencia como un crimen
la violencia sexual las demandas que son
acatadas por el estado son mínimas y la
espera pues para una demanda es larga y
en ese tiempo la salud mental de la
mujer se compromete considerablemente en
el caso específico de canadá la
violencia sexual se da solamente en el
seno de las comunidades indígenas en
absoluto se da permanentemente todos los
días
cotidianamente en las mujeres en el
trabajo en el hogar de las mujeres no en
las universidades de las universidades
hacemos trabajos en civiles en los
colegios en la cultura la cultura de la
violación porque es permanente y el
incesto es uno de los casos también
considerables tenemos grupos de
asistencia en grupos y tenemos una
demanda permanente de mujeres que han
sido víctimas del incesto y que siguen
siéndolo también es bueno
carlos porque por lo general cuando se
habla de abuso sexual en canadá se
piensa pura y exclusivamente las
comunidades indígenas como si fuera allí
el único lugar en el que se produce el
abuso sexual y eso es un acto y un
delito que está presente en otros
segmentos de esta sociedad a pesar de la
existencia de normas muy estrictas que
lo penalizan un cierto una cosa
particular que coincide un poco en lo
que dice amelia es que en este mismo
sondeo del que les hablaba esta mañana
la mayoría de las mujeres canadienses
dice haber experimentado algún tipo de
discriminación de género y la mayoría se
sucede en el trabajo y también dicen que
sus ideas se toman menos en cuenta menos
en serio debido a su género en el ámbito
laboral en el ámbito escolar
entonces en ámbitos digamos formales
también las mujeres sienten el tipo de
violencia que puede no ser física pero
también es una violencia en cuanto a
ideas y en cuanto a maneras de
presentarse ante ante los colegas
etcétera entonces la violencia aquí en
canadá se vive de distintas maneras
también y ligado eso
bueno de hecho el tema de la inequidad
salarial es algo que todavía hoy se
sigue discutiendo y yo honestamente
aunque parezca estúpido decirlo es algo
que sigo sin entender es como resulta
tan difícil resolver un tema como ese
cuando es muy simple se tipifica un
puesto laboral se le asigna una
retribución salarial y esa retribuciones
a ese puesto sea que el mismo sea
ocupado para el hombre o para la mujer
pero sin embargo sabemos que esto no es
así públicamente porque es tan difícil
resolver algo tan si regresamos y al
mismo tema que estamos platicando que es
el de la conciencia y cómo la gente va
forjando las percepciones que son
aprendidas en tu cultura no entonces sí
sí desde que eres pequeña o pequeño te
empiezan de una manera muy sutil a
enseñar que una persona por una
característica específico tiene más
valor que otra empiezas a realizar ese
comportamiento de manera sistemática sin
una conciencia porque lo adquiriste de
muy pequeña de muy pequeño y porque se
piensa que está bien claro porque es que
si así lo hacen mis papás y así lo hacen
mis tíos y mis tías en nuestros primeros
pasos de más de convivencia llegas al
trabajo y dices y muchas veces por eso
la conciencia es inconscientemente que
lo que lo realizas y por eso genera
mucha violencia incluso las personas
violencia sin darse cuenta a nosotras
mismas no mujeres que replican este tipo
de comportamientos que no son
conscientes que se están dañando a ellas
que dicen sí hay que dar un salario
menor
obviamente hombres también pero la
importancia de cómo romper esas
estructuras y esas percepciones no y por
eso los espacios educativos juegan un
papel vital en esta transformación no
hay en esta visibilidad de
visibilización de las dinámicas de
género las dinámicas sociales hay una
cosa que me llama mucho la atención luis
es que en general somos las mujeres que
hablamos de la igualdad de género no
entiendo porque no entiendo porque no
hay una implicación mucho más grande de
parte de los hombres con respecto a esta
equidad porque en realidad nos
y todos lo decíamos hace un momento
todos ganaríamos si las sociedades
fueran más equitativas entonces no
entiendo por qué cada vez que hay una
cuestión relacionada con la igualdad de
género son las mujeres que la ponen de
frente porque la llevan siempre de
frente a las mujeres sin que sean los
hombres quien también colaboren en el
romelio tiene las respuestas
al menos una reflexión me parece muy
interesante lo que tú dices porque la
responsabilidad de la violencia que la
mujer vive sigue teniéndolo a la mujer y
al hombre se de responsabiliza de esa
realidad y recibimos permanentemente
llamados de las universidades y todo
para formar a las mujeres prepararlas
para evitar la violencia pero a los
hombres nunca se les llama y son ellos
los causantes por ejemplo de la
violencia sexual pero es la mujer la que
estará allí preparándose para que no sea
agredida sexualmente entonces no se
sensibiliza siquiera al hombre al niño
por ejemplo cual pequeño la mamá le dice
mucho cuidado no le hable a nada
evitando por ejemplo el incesto pero se
responsabiliza el niño pero el adulto no
se le explica las consecuencias
para la vida ese niño a vida
entonces la responsabilidad sigue siendo
sobre la víctima y no sobre el agresor y
lo mismo sucede entonces siempre somos
las mujeres las que debemos
sensibilizarnos pero el hombre no está
ahí presente y me llamó me llamó la
atención recientemente una una campaña
que se vivió en la es una escuela
secundaria en la que va la que va mi
hijo en la que les prohibieron a las
niñas vestirse con cierto tipo de ropa
no se pueden vestir con con tirante
delgadito no se pueden vestir con shorts
pequeños y entonces las niñas se
manifestaron y dijeron porque somos
nosotras que no podemos vestirnos así
porque lo que les argumentaban es que
están llamando la atención de los
hombres es que son negros la ciencia
ción que el hombre la greda es estar
también lo que hay detrás de pensar pero
esta es mi culpa de la mujer o de la
niña que se vistió así de una forma
provocativa y entonces el hombre
pues reaccionó frente a esa provocación
entonces la culpable y la que tiene que
resolver el problema es de ella entonces
siempre la solución va hacia la persona
que es víctima eso es lo que hay que
cambiar en nuestra sociedad
estas niños estaban diciendo niñas
adolescentes de 13 14 años dijeron
porque somos nosotros que tenemos que
cambiar de actitud y de ropa y aparte
que eso lleva a que el problema sea como
individual el problema es porque yo no
estoy así mal y no porque es un problema
de suciedad que hay que cambiar y la
culpa es mía individual pero el
ejercicio es sistemática la violencia es
sistemática
yo quería como poner un ejemplo de uno
de nuestros participantes en uno de los
grupos ya es enfermera en un instituto y
tiene un cargo inclusive de coordinadora
que es una mujer muy bella y ha tenido
como un acoso sexual con palabras gestos
de uno de los compañeros que él ha
afectado notablemente porque ya había
habido ya una agresión sexual
cuando era niña y pero esto es
permanente ella habla con la informa de
esa situación y en él se le dice no
porque ese es el precio a que usted sea
muy bonita que ella dejó debes de
arreglarse no se pinta no hace nada
porque si la persona sigue acosando la
hasta que tuvo que pedir cómo se sintió
realmente muy vulnerable
y ahora está considerada como una
persona que tiene problemas de
adaptación o sea la violencia es
ejercida sobre ellas ya debe adaptarse y
el problema que no se adapte es de ese
es un problema personal entonces es muy
grave esa situación antes de ir a otra
pausa quería tocar brevemente porque me
gustaría reservar los últimos minutos
para dar una visión también positiva
porque era mujer ha avanzado mucho en el
terreno de la lucha de sus derechos
y sobre todo nos toca a nosotros que
somos todos los latinoamericanos quería
abordar brevemente el tema de la
educación porque es algo que se suele
pasar por alto
últimamente se cree se piensa que el
derecho a la educación ya ha sido
conseguido en todas partes del mundo
sobre todo en los países más
desarrollados pero nosotros sabemos que
en nuestros países la situación no
siempre es igualitaria y que todavía en
el día de hoy se dan grandes
desproporciones en la posibilidad de
acceder a una formación a una educación
en todo caso formal e institucional
perdón para todas las mujeres en todos
los países de américa latina que como
como como pienso
es este tema porque es aún difícil que
una mujer pueda acceder por ejemplo a
algunas carreras universitarias
yo te da cuenta mi experiencia personal
yo soy mujer y soy teólogo cuando yo
empecé a estudiar teología en colombia
fue gracias a la apertura que tuvo la
universidad san buenaventura para que
las mujeres pudiéramos participar en una
carrera que era de hombres todas las
cosas de la iglesia eran propiedad de
los hombres y siguen siéndolo aquí y
allá a mí me gustó mucho la teología en
ese momento había un boom de la teología
de la liberación en américa del sur con
brasil y perú y en colombia pues
empezamos a enterarnos de qué era eso a
mí me gustó mucho yo hice la carrera con
muchas dificultades porque es un mundo
de hombres mis profesores eran hombres y
mujeres muy poquitas mujeres en
comparación de los hombres la carrera es
muy linda me dio la oportunidad de
trabajar en pastoral social como agente
de cambio y eso es enfrentarse a un
sistema patriarcal es enfrentarse a un
sistema económico que después se fue
degenerando en lo que es el capitalismo
de hoy en día
y yo me veía como mujer muchas veces
frente a muchos obispos muchas veces
frente a sacerdotes y sobre con hombres
y yo les trataba de explicar nuestro
punto de vista pero eso era como una
cosa rarísima y ella porque estudió y
ella porque la aceptaron y como tú
decías hace un rato es que yo soy la
culpable de haber querido optado por una
carrera de hombres entonces yo sé lo que
me tengo que adaptar y yo decía esto es
injusto la situación de las mujeres es
injusta las situaciones de las mujeres
en el campo es de injusta y esa palabra
parecía que les dolía parecía que ellos
no podían aceptar que se lo dijera yo si
lo decía un sacerdote un como un cura o
un hombre aceptado
está bien si decía lo mismo exactamente
las mismas palabras y los mismos
razonamientos están bien pero como era
una mujer la que nos está diciendo
entonces uno pero pero como entonces
desenvolverse en un mundo de hombres con
una profesión de hombres no es nada
fácil pero yo sigo adelante yo aquí soy
capellán a en una prisión y trabajo con
con hombres
estoy haciendo todo lo posible por
cambiar la sociedad aquí y allá es la
prisión que me comentaste que está
operada completamente por mujer el 95%
de la administración de la prisión son
mujeres la directora es una mujer la
subdirectora y el resto todas son
mujeres
bueno yo apoyo a teresa teresa en la el
concepto que ya tiene somos la onu de la
sociedad patriarcal y de la sharía
patriarcal no social de poder relaciones
de poder las mujeres seguimos
y aún tenemos el mito y somos juzgadas
hay muchos prejuicios y se considera la
mujer que ya está para servir siempre en
el concepto de servir el país ratificar
y sacrificarse por eso las provisiones
son educación enfermeras secretarias
todas las que desean servir y cuidar al
otro porque estamos todavía en ese rol
patriarcal donde nosotros amac si es
para servir
y ahí de ahí que muchas de esas carreras
que se consideran de hombres que son
carreras donde no es el servicio pero de
otra manera el servicio pero mucho más
digamos enriquecedor es desde otro punto
de vista son negadas de la mujer vamos a
hacer una pequeña pausa la última y
después volvemos con una mirada positiva
sobre el rol de la mujer en nuestro
tiempo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno paloma tienes mensajes tengo aquí
unos mensajes que nos han llegado
durante la transmisión del programa no
no los puedo leer todos porque queremos
concluir pero quiero decir los nombres
de nuestros fieles oyentes javier
gonzález nunca hará y dice rápidamente
la mujer es importante en todos los
ámbitos de la vida feliz día de la mujer
saludos a todos en el castro cibernético
y bueno esta fm radio sólo éxitos
saludándonos a todas las que estamos
aquí ya luís también a gustavo lucas
también mandan mensajes para las mujeres
en este día de felicitaciones y nelson
contreras rincón desde barranquilla
colombia perfecto nos quedan solamente
dos minutos pero no quería dejar de dar
una visión positiva sobre el rol que
está jugando la mujer particularmente en
el caso de américa latina porque como lo
dijimos al comienzo de nuestra emisión
cuando otros segmentos de la sociedad
parecen estar en retirada en los últimos
tiempos la mujer en diversos países
latinoamericanos y tenemos ejemplos en
mexico en chile en argentina en
distintas partes en colombia también ha
salido a la calle a ganar
a la calle encabeza los reclamos de tipo
social en no pocos casos se trata
precisamente de las más jóvenes las que
llevan adelante esa lucha entonces yo
quería saber qué opinan ustedes de este
rol de preeminencia de la mujer en el
caso específico de américa latina
llevando adelante las luchas sociales
porque se da como se ha dado como se ha
llegado
yo quiero remitir a argentina
precisamente a la lucha que hicieron las
mujeres de la plaza de mayo hace tanto
tiempo y que duró fue una lucha muy
larga a ellas las llamaban locas al
principio y no entendía lo que ellas
estaban haciendo y lograron recuperar
por lo menos a sus nietos porque sus
hijos ya desaparecieron pero lograron
explicarle al mundo que era lo que
estaba pasando en argentina así como
ellas también la autora andrea d'atri
que escribe libro pan y rosas está
haciendo un paseo por toda américa
latina y europa explicando y contando lo
que hace el movimiento de mujeres en
todas partes entonces ahí estamos
adelante luchando y seguiremos y las
mujeres tenemos una fuerza interior
extraordinaria somos nosotros las que
protegemos los hijos los que llevamos
adelante las grandes movilizaciones a
través de las historias en la mujer él
es quien se ha movilizado por ejemplo en
los países nuestros que llegan las
grandes multinacionales a acabar con las
comunidades a quitarnos nuestros
recursos naturales son las mujeres las
primeras que salen avances a pesar de
que son militarizadas y que viven las
consecuencias de esa violenta
las mujeres somos unas luchadoras por
eso yo quiero invitarlos hoy a la
movilización que vamos a hacer las
mujeres con motivo del 8 de mayo en la
vamos a salir de las encartaciones clave
vamos a reunirnos ahí y vamos a hacer
una movilización para decir no más basta
toda la violencia factor que a las cinco
y media y mónica
definitivamente hay una energía renovada
en américa latina' las mujeres jóvenes
están tomando los espacios
se están llegando las herramientas que
tienen redes sociales y el saber te
acompañada
te permite como tomar vuelo y gritar más
fuerte y correr más rápido y brincar más
alto y estamos forjando una hermandad en
américa latina y lo vemos con los
movimientos que se están dando en los
diferentes países y cómo nos estamos
enlazando y generando redes y
contactando y
creo que no tenemos más tiempo les
agradecemos a todos ustedes la presencia
aquí en este estudio feliz día de la
mujer y a nuestro auditorio les
agradecemos como siempre haber estado
aquí y será hasta la próxima semana
gracias por las lecciones que alguien